all right what's up my name is Alan
dragu and today I'm going to walk you
through one email that made my client $
8,198 in one email and mind you this is
a very tiny list this is a list of
532 people super fun we're going to dive
into every aspect we're going to break
it down so let's go ahead and fire that
thing up actually hold on before we do
that make sure to like And subscribe
before we continue on with the video all
right now that we've got that out of the
way let's dive in all right let me go
ahead and share my screen here it is
it's coming it's almost bam all right so
diving in it's just a Google Docs is how
I write for my clients I put into Google
Docs and allow them to do comments and
all that stuff like that all right so
diving in for context this is a local
farm and he sells Farm F raised meat
okay farm raised meat eggs steaks all oh
golly it's so good it's so good all
right and so this is who I'm writing for
and his target audience are uh
middleaged families like 30s 40s with
kids health conscious stuff like that so
that's who we're writing to all right so
now that we got I'm looking at my IP I
got my iPad that's why I'm doing it all
right so I'm casting my screen here
let's do it so the subject line is five
reason reasons you shouldn't buy organic
okay so a couple of things on why this
subject line absolutely smashed is one
it's a listicle five reasons okay so
people know what they're getting into
okay yeah five I can I can buy to five
reasons so listicles are really powerful
okay you shouldn't buy organic is
challenging existing dogas so everybody
thinks organic is super super healthy
and so now I'm coming in their inbox and
I'm saying wrong you don't know what
you're doing you don't know what you're
talking about so I challenged their
existing dogma and the third thing is
it's really curious like what the heck
curiosity is the most powerful drug of
any email subject line and we've got
that riddle so we've got the listic goal
we've got challenge existing dogma and
we've got curiosity all in the subject
line making it a absolute smash house we
knew was going to be a banger all right
and then the preview text and what's
better than organic in the preview text
I like to agitate the Curiosity so
whatever got them curious I like to
twist the knife as they call it right to
say aren't you just a little bit more
Curious and so I like to put that in the
preview text all right I'm going to read
some of this email and then break it
down so as you can see this is a
straight listicle view I mean it's like
one 2 3 4 5 and then I flip it and I'll
show you what I'm doing here okay so the
first thing is like you'll read itical
things like organic animals live in a
still live in an overcrowded steel
houses which makes them deathly sick
okay so that's one thing that they
probably didn't know they probably
didn't like oh my gosh so organic
Animals still do that so now I'm giving
them new information and in a very um
fast rate of Revelation is what they
call is the faster that you reveal new
information the more dopamine that
people have so I just revealed a new P
of information to them and then I'm
going to keep going and freaking hit
them hard and number two organic can
mean that they eat organic grain that's
how low the standards are meaning
they're not eating plants and and all
the good things that give them it's just
organic grain uh again another piece of
information number three organic is
still processed in a factory with
non-organic Meats which means cancerous
cross-contamination okay you probably
catch what I'm doing here is I'm
injecting
fear okay I'm injecting their greatest
fear which again I'm talking about 30
and 40 year olds families with kids the
reason they buy this stuff is cuz they
want to be healthy and I'm bursting
their little bubble they got a bubble po
I'm popping it and I'm telling them you
should be terrified of organic okay fear
is a massive massive way to get somebody
to buy somebody especially when you
challenge your existing dog okay so I'll
do that a couple more times organic
still uses gross p pesticides herbicides
synthetics antibiotics just organic
versions of them no thanks all right
that's a you'll catch some of those the
parenthesis no thanks things like that
I'm doing to inject personality because
I'm talking about you know things that
you're like oh this isn't Fun pesticides
and herbicides and and non-organic gr
this is not fun make it fun all right
make it a little bit light-hearted for
them and so I'm injecting personality
into what otherwise would be just like
facts and boring oh well organic best
the set you don't want to do that boring
is the death of emails which means it's
the death of sales and then I flip it on
them okay so now you'll get to the part
where it says now here are five juicy
throw this on your grill reasons my farm
blows organic out of the barn okay first
off that's just fun again juicy throw
this on your girl reasons okay I'm
making it fun here are five reasons okay
I made it way funner in the email
another thing is I'm throwing five more
reasons and uh wink wink these are just
bullets as to why they should buy my
stuff but I'm giving them the
information of why our stuff is better
than organic but really what I'm doing
is I'm giving them a sales pitch but I'm
making it fun number one there isn't a
lick of pesticides herbicides
antibiotics vaccines medicines or even
mosquito spray on hope well Farms that's
my buddy's Farm hope well Farms only
god-given ingredients like sun water and
plants okay so now I just position the
enemy the enemy is organic so in the
email I'm literally positioning we are
the good guys and there is an enemy so
now I just flipped it okay so now you
put an enemy in there the next thing is
my 43 cows 800 chickens 50 pigs Ram 43
Acres of Glorious Rand all day long 24
hours a day that is social proof I'm
talking about all this stuff that we
have 43 cows 800 chickets 50 pigs Raman
43 acres of land so one it's healthy but
two it's social proof number three my
meats are so nutrient-dense from all the
plants that uh that they eat that even
Gordon Ramsay could taste the difference
could he taste the difference I'm sure
he could did he I don't know but it's
fun and again I'm kind of hijacking
Gordon as social proof even though he's
never eating the meat it's just fun and
I didn't say he did eat it but again it
feels like social proof so it's fun
number four we process everything on
farms not factories that's just good
alliteration Farms not factories number
five my animals are never sick and I
never give them medicine and if one did
get sick I wouldn't feed it to you
that's again brand enemy these guys are
feeding you sick animals okay I would
never do that to you so I'm elevating my
farm against the factories the enem me
and then I wrap it up so if you're like
my family cuz I'm targeting families and
you want to enjoy guilt-free steak
brisket sausage I'm making them water
out the mouth here I'm teasing them and
practically anything else that you could
throw on your grill oven or Skillet then
click the link below you have to tell
them what to do if you don't tell them
what to do they're like where's the link
okay they're not down but you get what
I'm saying you got to tell them what to
do and then I put the big ugly Link in
there no button none of that stuff the
big ugly link because that's how you do
it do you notice I didn't even have to
put a picture you notice that I didn't
even use an image I didn't use an image
of a grill of a steak of anything I just
posted this and they bought and then
after that your support of our little uh
of our little family farm means the
world to me and my family make it
personal tie that off make it a little
bit emotional okay till next time your
friend farmer Phil PS everything is Farm
Fresh juicy meats are limited grab your
favorites fact okay so I'm wrapping this
up cuz the PS is the second most read
part of an email and so I like to use
that as the scarcity mindset right PS we
don't have a lot of them so click the
freaking link okay or Ps 20% discount or
Ps when you do this today you get an
extra blah blah blah give them some kind
of incentive to click the link now so
that's it that's the email that made
over $88,000 in one email for a small
farm with a small list all because we
just we're really smart with every
strategy in our copyrighting and so by
the way if you want to grab that email I
left it in the description below you can
just click it have it read it study it
don't don't steal it you could get
inspiration from it don't steal it write
your own crap okay write your own crap
but until next time if you guys like
this uh go ahead and like And subscribe
the channel and let me know and I'll do
more of these I'll do more breakdowns if
they are helpful for you otherwise catch
you next time bye oh oh still
here well that's good you can watch the
next I got more videos you can watch
more if you want go ahead click it yeah
yeah click
it yeah of course you can don't hold
yourself back indulge in my
channel yeah you're GNA like it